[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض ونرصده معكم ابرز
المستجدات في العناوين
جديده
امام سجن كرج
[تصفيق]
الدفاع البريطانيه تقول ان روسيا استخدمت
مقاتله سخيفل من الجيل الخامس في اوكرانيا
على واقع القلق الامريكي من توجهات حكومه
نتنياهو بلنكين يزور اسرائيل نهايه الشهر
الجاري
رئيس هيئه قناه السويس يؤكد بالعربيه
النجاح سفينه جلوري لم يؤثر على حركه
الملاحه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا اصدر القضاء الايراني
واحكاما باعدام ثلاثه محتاجين من محافظه
اصفهان بدريعه مشاركته في اعمال شغب
واتهامهم بالحرابه وبحسب بيان من القبائل
الايراني فان المحكومين بالاعدام هم صالح
مير هاشمي ومجد كاظمي وسعيد يعقوب ليرتفع
بذلك عبد الصادره ضدهم احكام بالاعدام الى
17 تم تنفيذ اربعه منها والمصادقه على
حكمين اخرين من المحكمه العليا هذا هو
اعرب نشطاء حقوق الانسان في ايران عن
قلقهم من احتمال تنفيذ حكم الاعدام بحق
اثنين من المتطهرين هما محمد
اجبهني فقد توجه عدد كبير من المواطنين
الى سجن رجاء شهر من مدن كرج وطهران
وارامين
يحتمل اعدامهما اليوم الاثنين واظهرت
مقاطع الفيديو من مدينه كرج تجمع عشرات
المواطنين امام بوابه السجن تمديدا بعزم
النظام اعدام المت وفي هذه الاثناء سمع
دوي اطلاق نار بالقرب من السجن
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لحقوق الانسان احكام الاعدام التي اصدرها
النظام الايراني تجاه عدد من المحتجين
المنظمه اشار الى ان بين الايرانيين
المعتقلين محمد
بهتلو يواجهاني خطا الاعدام في الساعات
المقبله مضيفه ان عدد المجتمع الدولي ان
يفعل كل ما في وسعه وقفه اعدام سلطات
النظام المحتاجين الايرانيين
الشرطي قتل في مكان اخر حسب موقع الشرطه
نفسه اي انه قتل في مدينه الرباط كريم
ولكن نسبه الى ملف ابني هذا ما ذكره موقع
الشرطه عندما كان الشرطي ملقا على الارض
ركله الناس الا انهم نسبوه الى ملف ابني
حتى يعدموه كما قال الخطيب في يوم تشيع
جثمان القتيل كرمبور بانهم تجمعوا عليه
هنا وقتلوه هنا ما يعني انه قتل خلال
اشتباك وليس نتيجه لدعسه بسياره الجميع
يعلم ذلك لكن تعمدوا ان ينسبوه الى ملف
ابنه ليشنقوه هؤلاء يمارسون الظلمه انهم
ظلمه
[تصفيق]
مسلسل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
متابعه لهذا الموضوع مشاهدينا معنا في
الاستديو السيد صالح حميد الباحث في الشيء
الايراني اهلا وسهلا معنا في هذه النشره
يعني حتى هذا الصباح كنا نتحدث عن امكانيه
اعدام كل من بروكليو من عدمها حتى تفاجئنا
النظام طبعا
باصدار ثلاثه احكام جديده هل يمكن للضغوط
الداخليه والخارجيه المفروضه حاليا على
النظام ان تثنيها عن تنفيذ مثل هذه
الاعدامات بالطبع النظام يعني منذ عقود
ليس فقط الان وخلال هذه الاحتجاجات يريد
من خلال هذه الاعدامات المستمره ان يبث
الرعب والخوف ويعول على هذا القلب بايقاف
هذه المظاهرات لكن من الواضح ان النتائج
لا زالت عكسيه ليله البارحه شاهدنا
مظاهرات واسعه في مدن كبرى مثل طهران
ومشهد واصفهان همم وايضا كان هناك تجمع
كبير لاسر ضحايا طائره الاوكرانيه التي
سقطها الحرس الثوري همم يعني هذه
الاعدامات همم
يمكن ان نصفها بانها انتقاميه اي ان
النظام يريد همم ان همم يقول همم قوات
الامن والبسيج والحرس الثوري بانه سيحاسب
وسيقتل المتظاهرين الذين يقاومون همم
القوات الامنيه حتى لو كانت هذه المحاكمات
الصوريه
والسريعه والعارجه التي تفتقر الى ادنى
شروط يعني ومعايير المحاكمات العادله حتى
حسب القوانين الايرانيه نفسها يعني هو من
الواضح كما تفضلت على هذه الاعدامات
التحميل في حياتها رسائل داخليه عطفا على
هذه الاحتجاجات لكن هل تحمل ايضا رسائل
خارجي المجتمع الدولي
كما نرى يعني الموقف الدول لهذه المره
مختلفه تماما عن المرات السابقه مثلا في
الاحتجاجات 2019
الدول فقط ببيانات الادانه الان هناك
خطوات اكثر هناك عقوبات جديده وهناك لجنه
حقائق شكلت من قبل مجلس حقوق الانسان تم
طرد ايران من نظمت المراه في الامم
المتحده هذه الخطوات كلها بالاضافه الى
بيانات الادانه من رؤساء الدول مثلا همم
البارحه راينا رئيس الوزراء الكندي كيف
اشار بوضوح الى سلوك الارهابي والقمعي
للنظام الايراني كلها هذه العوامل ادت الى
زياده زخم المظاهرات لانه الايرانيون
كانوا دائما يخشون من موقف مهاد للنظام
وعدم اسماء اصواتهم الان يبدوا الامر
مختلف تماما همم يعني الان الحراك يكمل
شهر الرابع وكان النظام يروج بان
المظاهرات انتهت وهناك فقط بعد التجمعات
الصغيره لكن ما شاهدناه البارحه مختلف
تماما وهمم يعني همم نرى بوضوح استمرار
هذه المظاهرات بزخم اكبر طيب يا صالح هذا
الخبر العاجل على شاشه العربيه قناه
السويس تعلن النجاح عمليات تعويم السفينه
جلوري وعوده الملح لطبيعتها
طيب بس صالح يعني رقم تفضلت به لكن مازالت
الرسائل خفيه التي يريد ان يرسلها النظام
ايراني للمجتمع الدولي ماذا يريد ان يقول
تحديدا همم رغم المناشده الكبير التي توجه
اليه بوقفات الادامات ماذا يريد ان يقول
المجتمع الدولي تحديدا المجتمع همم الدولي
يعني لم يتخذ بعد الخطوات الكافيه هناك
يعني ادوات الضغط عديده لم يستخدمها بعد
ما زال النظام الايراني وممثلا في مؤسسات
الامم المتحده هناك سفارات لكن الان هناك
مطالبات ومناشدات بطرد سفراء النظام
الايراني النظام بالطبع يريد ان يقول همم
انه يتجاهل كل هذه الاصوات والمناشدات
ويستمر على نفس نهج الاعدامات وبالمناسبه
سجن الرجاء شهر في شهر هذا هو نفسه السجن
الذي شهد الاعدامات الجماعيه للسجناء
السياسيين في عام 1988 من النظام يريد ان
يقول بانه سيستمر على نفس لكن همم مره
اخرى نقول ان النتائج عكسيه وهذا سيفسر
سبب استمرار المظاهرات الحائره
الصالح حميد الباحث في الشان الايراني
تحياتي اليك
اذا مشاهدينا الى ردود الفعل الدوليه على
احكام الاعدام التي يصدرها النظام بحق
المحتجين حيث اعلنت بلجيكا
بلجيكا وهولندا والدنمارك انها ستستدعي
سفراء ايران لديها ردا على اعدام شابين في
ايران على اصله بالاحتجاجات الشعبيه وعبرت
وزيره خارجيه بلجيكيه حجه الحبيب على
تويتر
الى ان حزمه رابعه من العقوبات الطائران
قيد الاعدادات قبل انعقاد مجلس الشؤون
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي المقرر في
الثالث والعشرين من الشهر الجاري
هذا وتجدد هذه المثيرات الاحتجاجيه
المناهضه النظام الايراني داخل البلاد
وخارجها وسط غضب عار من تنفيذ حكم
بالاعدام على موقفنا في الاحتجاجات وشاهد
الطيران وعدد ايضا من المدن الايرانيه
مسيرات الاحتجاجيه ونشرح حساب
1500 تصوير مقطع فيديو يظهر متظاهرين في
ظهران يرددون شعاره منها الموت جمهوريه
الاعدامات والموت للديكتاتور
[موسيقى]
يا ماما
لم تهدي الاحداث في منطقتنا حتى يومنا هذا
واليوم قبل ان يستريح العالم بعد جائعه
طالت البشريه جمعاء تفجرت ازمات جديده
ولكن هذه المره على مستوى العالمي
كم هائل من الاحداث والمعلومات يتدفق كل
يوم اخبار حروب وتداعيات سياسيه واقتصاديه
اصبح ما بين السطور اكثر من السطور
اسلوبا جديده
[موسيقى]
ايه يا اسلوب حياه للملايين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
حول العالم
تقارير ميادين اللعب
[تصفيق]
اخبار الرياضه في هذه الاوقات على شاشه
العربيه
[موسيقى]
بصوارخ بعيده المدى من الاجواء الروسيه
الدفاع البريطانيه صوره بالاقمار الصناعيه
وذلك في نهايه ديسمبر الماضي
هي الاكثر تطورا من الجيل الخامس وتستخدم
تقنيات التخفي والالكترونيات الطيران
المتقدمه للغايه
الجيش الاخراني شن سبع و20 ضربه جويه
وصاروخيه على مواقع روسيه في 24 ساعه
واضاف الجيش الاوكراني في بيانه اليوم ان
روسيا تشنها هجمات كثيفه في محاوله للتقدم
في محاور محمود ولمان وكوفيناسك الا انها
اجبرت القوه الروسيه عن البقاء في حاله
دفاع بمحاور زابوريا وخيرسون واشار جيش
الاوكراني الى تدمير معدات عسكريه
واستهداف مراكز صيانتها مؤكدا ان الجنود
بلاروس يشاركون بنشاط في عمليات صيانه
الاسلحه والدبابات الروسيه
مشاهدينا ايضا نفى الجيش الاوكراني ما
قالته موسكو عن مقتل 600 من جنوده في
قصفلوسج على كرامتهاسك شرقي بهذا وقال
متحدث باسم القياده الشرقيه للجيش
الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه ليست لديها
القدره علشان ضربه شديده الدقاء مرددا لما
وصفه بالعمليه الاعلاميه روسيه في مواجهه
النجاحات الاوكرانيه على حد تعبيرها
مشاهدينا معنا من موسكو العربيه
اذا كيف كان اذا اصداء او كان صدى هذه
الضربه الروسيه على اكرامه خاصك التي يقول
جيش روسي انها اخذت 600 من الجنود
الاوكرانيين
مرحبا احمد بالفعل روسيا كانت قد اعلنت
انها قامت بتوجيه ضربه انتقاميه ردا على
الضربه التي وجهها واجهتها اوكرانيا وادعت
الى مقتل قوات روسيه نحو 60
مقاتله روسي ليله راس السنه كانت توجيه
ضربه قويه كانت قد قالت انها قتلت فيها
نحو 6
اوكراني كان هناك تكسيف ليه الضربات
الروسيه يوم امس بعد انتهاء الهدنه التي
اعلنتها طبعا روسيا والتي اعتبرت ان
اوكرانيا لم تقوم بالالتزام بهذه الهجره
للاحتفال المواطنين الروس والاكرانيين في
ليله عيد الميلاد طبعا همم نتيجه تكثيف
هذه ضربات منذ قليل اعلنت قوات الانفصاليه
لانها قامت همم
بالسيطره على المنطقه
وهي في اتجاه دار همم هناك معارك همم
عنيفه تجري في هذه المنطقه همم في اتجاه
سيدار للسيطره ايضا على هذه المنطقه طبعا
هذه المناطق هي تقع في منطقه همم التي
تسيطر عليها القوات الاوكرانيه القوات
الانفصاليه منذ قليل اعلن السيطره عنها
على منطقه همم في اندونيسك التي تسيطر
عليها القوات الاوكرانيه طبعا القوات
الانفصاليه اعلنت تهنئها تقوم بتعزيز
الدفاعات الجويه همم هناك وهناك محاوله
لابعاد خطوط القتال عن المدن الكبرى
لحمايتها طبعا بعد قصف المكثف التي شهدت
شهدته هذه المناطق طبعا خلال الهدنه وقبيل
الهدنه من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه كما تقول
القوات الانفصاليه
اخرى
هل قبل هذه الضربه هذه الانباء بارتياح
يوازي حاله الغضب همم التي همم اشاره بها
الروس بعد ضربه اا الضربه التي كانت في
مكه همم كيف كان صداها بالنسبه للراي
العام الروسي
يعني التفاعل بالقبل الجانب الروسي او من
قبل المواطنين الروس حول هذه الضربه التي
اوجهتها روسيا يوم امس مقتل ادت الى مقتل
600 مقاتل الاوكراني كما قالت موسكو هي
ايضا قليلا اثلجت طبعا القلوب هو بالاخص
هنا القوه المواطنين المؤيدين للعمليه
العسكريه ولكن هناك كان طبعا رده الفعل لا
تزال هناك همم هناك غضب قليل من الغضب من
قبل قوى الشارع الروسي بسبب مقتل القوات
الروسيه وهذا العدد الكبير الذي اعلنت عنه
الدفاع الروسيه مقتل القوات الروسيه وطبعا
في ليله راس السنه كان هو بمثابه ضربه
كبيره بالنسبه روسيا من جانب بالنسبه
الراي العام والشارع الروسي من جانب الاخر
احمد من مصر العربيه
وميكي مشاهدينا يضمنين الكاتب الصحفي محمد
البابا اهلا بك سيد البابا كما تابعنا
روسيا نفذ بل اوكرانيا هي التي نفذ طبعا
سقوط هذا عبد الكبير من اجلتها في هذه
المنطقه اللي هي كراسه
بدايه يعني لو تجمل لنا اهم المواقف
والتصريحات التي صدرت من الطرف الاوكراني
بهذا الخصوص
صباح الخير
بعض الصور التي وصلتنا من وزاره الدفاع
الاخرانيه عن المكان الذي تم استهدافه هذه
هي هذا هو احد الاماكن التي تم استهدافها
وواضح ان الصاروخ سقط الى جانب المبنى هذا
المبنى الذي يعتبر سكن طلاب في مدينه
كريمات رزق وهو مهجور وهنا قالت روسيا
انها قتلت اكثر من ست او بها يعني بحدود
600 جندي اوكراني نرى من خلال هذه الصوره
التي نشرتها وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
ونشرتها عدد من يعني وكالات الانباء مثل
رويترز
وهنا نرى يعني في الصور الاخرى هنا هذا هو
المكان الذي تم استهدافه وهدف الى جانب
المكان صاروخ سقط ام يعني في احد اماكن
الصغيره
يعني نرى هنا وكما يعني يقول الجانب
الاوكراني بعض الدمار بداخل احد المكاتب
في هذا المبنى يعني لا وجود له اثار هذه
الصوره بعد حوالي 20 دقيقه او 25 دقيقه من
تنفيذ
ثلاث الصاروخيه على مدينه الكراسه لذلك
يعني وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه تطحط بشكل
كامل ما نشرته وزاره الدفاع الروسيه من
يعني قاتل اكثر من 600 جندي داخل مدينه
كراماتك وايضا يعني كما قلت بالامس ونعيد
ونكرر وهذا مقالته هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه ان الجيش الاوكراني لا يضع
اعداد كبيره من الجنود في مكان واحد وهذه
استراتيجيه بدات تتبع منذ نهايه
شهرتي لانه كان عند الطلاب صحيح نعم يعني
هو مهجور منذ بدايه الحرب بعد اخلاء
الجامعات في تلك المدينه هذا مبنى الى حد
ما مهجور يعني بحسب الجيش الاوكراني قال
ان الصواريخ تساقطت عشوائيا في تلك
المنطقه هناك بعض القتله من المدنيين يعني
ما يقوله الجيش الاوكراني والاداره
المحليه في اكرامي ان الكتله جراءه ضربات
الصاروخيه على على كلماته جاءت من قبل
المد ولم يكن هناك اي موقف او يعني بيان
رسمي اوكراني عن سقوط اعداد من القتلى من
الجيش الاوكراني بحيث ان وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه كتكتم بشكل كبير عن سقوط
الضحايا ولكن يعني ما نريد يصالح ان وما
تاكد من خلال شهود اعيان من خلال صحفيين
اجانب زاروا اماكن سقوط الصواريخ وهم
مقيمين وموجودون في كلمته منذ الفتره
طويله يعرفون طبيعه المكان والجميع يعلم
ان القواعد العسكريه للجيش الاوكراني لا
تضم اعداد كبيره اكثر نقطه ممكن ان يتواجد
فيها جنود الجيش الاوكراني بين 15 الى 20
هذه هي طريقه انتشار القوات الاوكرانيه
المواقف الرسميه من وزاره الدفاع من
المكتب الرئاسه المستشارين الرئيس حتى
الشرقي الحكم العسكري همم لوغانسكو وهو
متواجد في تلك المنطقه قال ان يعني هذه
يعني اخبار تنشرها روسيا فقط لحفظ اسماء
الوجه مع الراي العام الروس
صحفيه محمد البابا شكرا جزيلا لك
مشاهدينا اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
تعزيز قواتها في منطقه زابوريج ولوجاست
تحسبا لهجوم الاوكراني المحتمل ومحاوله
فريق الخناق على القوات الاخرانيه في محيط
باخموطي سيطره على كامل دنيا اسكندر
روسيا تعزيز دفاعاتها في منطقه
اوكرانيا تحسبا لهجوم ربما ستشنه القوات
الاوكرانيه قريبا وفقا لتقرير
الاستخباراتيه بريطانيا التقرير البريطاني
رجح ان تحقق القوات الاوكرانيه تقدما
كبيرا في زموريجيا سيشكل تحديا للجسر
البري الروسي الذي يربط منطقه روستوف
الروسيه وشبه جزيره القرم اما في مدينه
بخمود فان المعارك تحتدمه هناك بالاضافه
الى وسط سوريدار بمقاطعه حيث يتواصل القصف
الروسي لدفع الجيش الاوكراني على الانسحاب
منها الى بق محمود
وتراهن روسي على استراتيجيه ذات محورين
اولهما تكثيف قوه النيران ومن الصواريخ
البحريه بعد الدفع بقطع حديثه مثبت عليها
صواريخ سيركن خلال الايام الماضيه والمحور
الثاني تضييق الخناق على القوات
الاوكرانيه في محيط بخمه اهم المعارك
الحاليه لسيطره على كامل دونتستك في
المقابل يقول تقرير حديث لمركز دراسه
الحرب الامريكي ان المكاسب الروسيه في
سندار لا تنظر بتطويق
لان الامر يتعلق بضروره السيطره على اثنين
من الطرق السريعه بطول 13 كيلو مترا بينما
تتقدم القوات الروسيه بصعوبه
افادت المصادر العربيه في الاردن برعايه
امريكيه يجمع قيادات في الجيش الذي مع
زعماء فصائل مسلحه في طرابلس و افخم مصاري
العربيه فان طائره خاصه غدا
العاصمه الاردنيه المصادر اضافه ان بعض
الشخصيات المقربه من التشكيلات المسلحه
خرجت عبر دفعه الى الاردن وبعضهم غادر عن
طريق تونس من اجل لقاء شخصيات الممثله
للشرق الليبي خصوصا بعد تسليم الاسرى في
الفتره الماضيه
اوضح رئيس المجلس الاعلى للدوله في ليبيا
خالد المشري ان الوثيقه الدستوريه الموز
مع اصدارها ستشترط الاستقاله على من
سيترشح لانتخابات الرئاسيه اذا كان مسؤولا
المشري مشاهدينا اضاف ان اصدار الوثيقه
دستوريه والقوانين الانتخابيه من المفترض
ان يتم خلال شهرين على اقصى تقدير وتوقع
رئيس مجلس الدوله اجراء الانتخابات
الرئاسيه والطلمانيه في اغسطس او سبتمبر
المقبلين وفيما يتعلقوا برئيس حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه المنتهيه ولايته عبد
الحميد الدبابه
سيقاتل لمنع اي خطوه تؤدي بالليبيين الى
الانتخابات الداعيا الدبابه الى مناظره
عالميه
قال رئيس المجلس الرئاسي الليبي محمد
المنيفي ان مفتاح الحل لازمه ليبيا ليس في
المحافظه للنفوذ والسلطه وليس في تقاسم
المالي والموارد ان مفتاح الحل لازمه هذا
الوطن هو ليس في المحافظه
السلطه والنفوذ وليس في تقاسم الموارد
والمال ولكنه في راب الصدى وجبر الضرر
والعفو والمصالحه انه في استعاده روح
الوحده الوطنيه الاخويه والعيش المشترك في
هذا الوطن المعطاه انه في رجوء الرجوع الى
حكمه الاجداد والاباء المؤسسين والاحتكام
الى قواعد العرف والدين والممارسات
السلميه والديمقراطيه في تسويه الصراع
ايها الساده ان كل الصيغ المجربه في ليبيا
لبناء السلطه بقت بالفشل لانها تجاهلت
الحل واحرقت المراحل
وقفزت على مطالب الشعب الليبي الى مطالب
الساسه
وقال رئيس المجلس الرئاسي الليبي الى
المجلس لم يكن يوما جزء من هذه المشكله
فقد وقف متماسكا على مسافه متساويه من
جميع اطراف الصراع على السلطه ولم يكن
يوما من المتمسكين بها او من متنافسين
عليها
ان المجلس الرئاسي الليبي لم يكن يوما
جزءا من هذه المشكله فقد وقف متماسكا على
مسافه متساويه من الجميع الاطراف اطراف
الصراع على السلطه التي لم يكن هو يوما من
المتمسكين بها او المتنافسين عليها وقد
التزم المجلس الرئاسي
بمهنته الثانيه في خلق الارضيه السياسيه
والقانونيه
والاجتماعيه للمصالحه وقد بذلنا وما زلنا
نبذه في سبيل هذا الهدف كل جهد ووقت في
ظروف كنا كلنا نعلم من البدايه انها لن
تكون مواتيه وان الانجاز المحرز لم يصل
بعد الى مرحله جني الثمار لمشروع المصالحه
الوطنيه
ومن جهه اخرى اعربه اللجنه الوطنيه لحقوق
الانسان في ليبيا عن ابتعاضها احتكار
المجلس الرئاسي لمشروع المصالحه الوطنيه
بعيدا عن مؤسسات الحقوقيه والقانونيه
واكلت اللجنه انه لا يمكن تحقيق المصالحه
الشامله والسلام في ليبيا بالاخصاء
والتهميش وانما من خلال مشاركه فاعله من
جميع المكونات الاجتماعيه والسياسيه وان
تكون نتائج حوار مجتمعا جاد وحقيقيه
مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
تدريبات عسكريه قربه ايوان مجددا والاخيره
تنجد
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد رحابه الخارجيه
السعوديه بانطلاق المرحله النهائيه من
عمليه السياسيه في السودان واكدت الوزاره
في بيان دعم الرياض الدائم لعوده
الاستقرار السياسييجي الى السودان
واستمرار المملكه في مساعها مع السودانيين
والشركاء الدوليين لتحقيق كل ما من شانه
السودان
مؤكد
للجميع
ونؤكد للشعب السوداني اننا لن نخزنه ولم
نتراجع عن ما اختطيناه
من مسير يفضي الى تحول الديمقراطي حقيقي
اي دور في هذا التحول او في هذا الانتقال
[تصفيق]
من جهته اكد نائب رئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني محمد حمدان نقله التزام المؤسسه
العسكريه بانهاء الوضع الراهن وتوقيع
اتفاق لتشكيل السلطه المدنيه كامله الامر
الذي يفرغ المؤسسه العسكريه لحمايه البلاد
تاتي هذه المناسبه اليوم
تاكدا على التزامنا السابق والمتجدد
بانهاء الوضع الراهن
اتفاق نهائي
[تصفيق]
تتشكل بموجبه السلطه مدنيه كامله
في المواجهه العسكريه
للاعداد لاعداد دورنا في حمايه البلاد من
المهدلات الخارجيه
والانقراض في مشروع الاصلاح الامني
والعسكري الشامل الذي يقود لجيش وطني واحد
مهني
وقومي لا علاقه له بالسياسه
الاتحاد الافريقي الى السودان الى الاتفاق
السياسيه الشامله والعدل يسمح للشعب
السوداني بالعوده الى الاستقرار
العظيم
بالعوده الى الاستقرار وان تكون له مؤسسه
مؤسسات شرعيه وان كانت انتقاليه
ونحن نجتمع هذا المساء في قاعه الصداقه
يتطلعوا اليكم الملايين من السودانيين في
جامع في جميع انحاء البلاد فضلا عن
اشقائكم واصدقائكم ومحبكم عبر المعموره
النتائج ايجابيه من شانها تحسين اوضاع
السودان بشكل مطلق
الممثل الاتحاد الافريقي الى السودان
بل ان السودانيين لفي 2 انذار العالم انهم
يتصالحون ويتعافون بعد الخصومات وحتى بعد
الحروب وقد شهدنا ذلك في ابو جا ونفاشه
وجوبا ولعل هذه الروح هي التي وراء
الاتفاق الاطاري الذي نعمل ان يكون بلسما
شافيا لاوضاع السودان
الافريقيه التي تتابع ما يجري في السودان
وتامل الاليه الثلاثيه ان يكون هذا
الاتفاق مرجعيه للتعافي الوطني
كامله
نحن نناشد الذين لم يلتحقوا بهذا الاتفاق
ان يلتحق الان الايطار حقيقه اصبح خطوه من
الماضي
الالتحاق بالاتفاق الايطالي ولكن
بقيه المسار والخطوات اللاحقه الوصول
الاتفاق النهائي تمر عبر ورش ومؤتمرات
القضايا وهذه يجب ان يشارك فيها الجميع
حركه تحرير السودان وحركه العدل والمساواه
فقط الحركتين اللي لم ينضموا للاتفاق بقيه
كل الحركات الواقعه على الاتفاق اليوبا هي
جزء من الاتفاق نحن مازلنا بنعمل انهم
يجوا ينضموا
لركب الاتفاق لانه قطع اشواط وطبعا ما
يتراجع هذا
الاتفاق الى الوراء لانه اي انتكاسه فيه
او اي تنصل منه يعني انه احنا هندخل مره
اخرى في دوامك الاضطراب وعدم الاستقرار
الا في اطار الديمقراطي هذا جوهره
اتفاقينا احنا عملنا في هذه الاتفاقيه
نعلم الجوهره وهذه الاتفاقيه مهمه وهذه
العمليه بما في ذلك التفكيك مهم لكل اهل
السودان وبالذات في مناطق النزاعات والحرب
ولذلك همم من المفيد ان تحسم هذه القوى
امرها لكي نصل الى مراتي جديده في تنفيذ
اتفاقيه السلام خطوات تقترب من الوصول
للانتفاده النهائي الذي يجمع السودانيين
ويوحدهم خلف حكومه مدنيه وقياده مدنيه
للدول السودانيه ويحدث ويؤكد التحول
المدني الديمقراطي المنشود عبر خروج
المؤسسه العسكريه من العمليه السياسيه
وقيام حكومه مدنيه تنتهي بمراحل
الانتقاليه تقوم في اخرها انتخابات يعبر
فيها ويختار فيها الشعب السوداني
يصل وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه نهايه الشهر
الجاري الى اسرائيل في زياره سيلتقي
خلالها رئيس حكومه الاسرائيليه
في القدس وتاتي الزياره على خلفيه تخوف
الاداره الامريكيه جميع الحكومه الجديده
برئاسه
التي ذكرت ان المستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي
في التاسعه عشر من الشهر الحالي
بشان مجموعه من القضايا من بينها ملف
ايران وايضا الملف الفلسطيني هو من
المتوقعات المتحده الشهر المقبل وفقا
للصحيفه
شرعا اسرائيل بتنفيذ عقوبات دعوى
فلسطينيين بحجه توجههم الى المحاكم
الدوليه ضدها وكان الاولى العقوبات سحب
بطاقه الشخصيه الهامه من وزير الخارجيه
فلسطينيه رياض المالكي اثناء مروره عبر مع
باي الكرامه الحدوديه مع الاردن
بدات اسرائيل اليوم بتنفيذ قرارات مجلس
الوزراء السياسي الامنيه الاسرائيلي
الكابنت بفرض عقوبات ضد السلطه الفلسطينيه
بحجه ان الفلسطينيين توجهوا الى محكمه
العدل الدوليه لطلب راي استشاري قانوني
حول المنظومه الاستعماريه الاسرائيليه
اثناء عوده معالي وزير الخارجيه
والمغتربين دكتور رياض المالكي ايه صباح
هذا اليوم الى ارض الوطن عائدا من
البرازيل تم سحب بطاقه ااه ما تسمى بطاقه
الفي اي بي وهمم خضع لكافه الاجراءات
التعسفيه المعتمده عند الجانب الاسرائيلي
على المعبر
سحبوا بطاقات الشخصيات الهامه من كبار
القاده الفلسطينيين كان من بين سلسله من
العقوبات التي هددت بها اسرائيل
وتعالت الاصوات مطالبه بتنفيذها عقوبه
مشاركه قيادات في السلطه الفلسطينيه في
استقبال الاسير كريم يونس في مناطق الخط
الاخضر بعد قضاء اربعين عاما في السجون
الاسرائيليه
تعتقد بانه يمكن مع هذه الحكومه
يعني خلق شركات دوليه كبيره للضغط على هذه
الحكومه داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي هذه
الحكومه غير مقبوله عقوبات ماليه
واقتصاديه تحت رهن التنفيذ قررتها اسرائيل
للضغط على الفلسطينيين من اجل الامتناع عن
طرح قضيتهم امام المؤسسات الحقوقيه
الدوليه
العقوبات هذه المره قالت
القاده الفلسطينيه في محاوله لكبح جماح
التحرك الدبلوماسي الفلسطيني الهادي في
الى اعاده القضيه الفلسطينيه الى المؤسسات
الدوليه من جديد
من امام حاجز بيت ايل شمال رام الله خالد
القاسم العربيه
تعويم السفينه جلوري وعوده الملاحه
لطبيعتها وكان رئيس هيئه قناه السويس
الفريق اسامه ربيع اكد في وقت السابق
للعربيه
لم يؤثر على حركه الملاحه مشيرا الى ان
السفينه جانا احد بشكل طفيف بقافله الجنوب
وجارنا تعويمها هذا هو كان الشركه الشحن
لايف قد اعلنت ان سفينه بلوري جانحت في
قناه السويس وتحاوله قاطره هيئه القناه
اعاده تعويمها
الان مشاهدينا الى وقفه مع اخوان الاقتصاد
مع الزميله راح
من جديد
مقابل الجنيه المصري يسجل الارتفاعات بصفر
فاصل 2 بالمئه في جلسه اليوم الى هذه
المستويات
27.25 اكيد كنا شفنا ضغط متتاليه على
الجنيه امام الدولار وخاصه بعد الخطوه
الاخيره همم
واجراءات اخيره رايناها من ضمن رفع
الفائده الى مستويات جدا مرتفعه الى 25%
من قبل همم مصرفين همم رئيسيين في مصر
مؤشرات المصريه
19% من الارتفاع و30
بنصف نقطه كيف تبدو الصوره باسواق الخليج
سوق الاسهم السعوديه مرتفع دبي ايضا ابو
ظبي تراجع بعض الشيء الكويت الاول خسائر
بصفر فاصل الاثنين بالمائه اليوم يضاف سهم
جاف اتش الى مؤشر الكويت الاول من المؤشر
الرئيسي وقطر على ارتفاع زين زين السهم
مرتفع بقوه فاصل 6% ابرز خبر نسمعه اليوم
من زين اتمت صفقه بيع البناء التحتيه
لابراجها لشركه لاتيس التي تم تاسيس لنقل
الابراج زين اليها زين السعوديه سوف تمتلك
20% من هذه الشركه 60% للبي اي اف والنسب
المتبقيه هي مملوكه للامير سعود بن فهد بن
عبد العزيز وشركه سلطان القابضه قيمه
الصفقه 3 مليار ما ستحصل عليه زين من
ارباح صافيه هو واحد فاصل واحد مليار ريال
توزع عند تسليم للابراج بالمرحله الاولى
سوف يتم تسليم 3000 برج من اصل 8000 برج
ومن ثم الابراج المتتاليه سوف يتم تسليما
على مرحله خلال عام ونصف تقريبا سهم اذا
يسجل قفزه اثر هذه الاخبار سهم اخر مرتفع
اليوم دار المعدات ترسي تعقد لمشروع مع
وزاره الصحه
195 مليون ريال والاثر المالي بتتوقعه
خلال الربع الثاني من عام و23 والسهم عبير
تفاعل في ظل هذه الاخبار تسجل المكاسب
اثنين فاصل اربعه في المئه مؤشر دبي مرتفع
الى هذه المستويات الاسهم الاكثر تداولا
من ضمن اعمار اعمار كانت المكاسب حدود
الواحد بالمئه على الان تتراجع بعض الشيء
الارتفاعات الامارات دبي الوطني خسائر
باكثر من واحد في المئه في ابو ظبي تراجع
بواحد بالمائه على مؤشر السوق اليوم صعب
فيه بعض الضغط هذه اسهم العالميه القابضه
الفضائي كلها خاسره ابو ظبي الاول ثلاثه
بالمئه من التراجع نتذكر هنا انه في
الاسبوع الماضي كنا عم نتحدث عن دراسه كان
يقوم بها ابو ظبي الاول
للاستحواذ على ساندريتش البنك البريطاني
وتم تخلي عن هذه الخطط ابو ظبي الاول اذا
همم متراجع بقوه في جلسه اليوم سريعا الى
الكويت اليوم
مؤشر الكويت الاول متراجع لاحد واجله
ثلاثه بالمئه بي ايضا على تراجع الوطني في
بعض الاستقرار زين ايضا وهذه الاسهم هي
الاكثر تداول ام في السوق الكويتيه قبل ان
نخطب مشاهدينا سريعا الى اسعار النفط التي
تسجل ارتفاعات في جلسه اليوم على خلفيه
تصريحات ايجابيه نسمعها من احد اعضاء
البنك المركزي
الصيني يتحدث فيها انه يتوقع تعافي سريع
للاقتصاد الصيني خاصه في ظل التحفيزات
اللي عم بتعطيها الصيني لتنوي اعطاءها
للاسر وللشركات لحمايتها من تداعياتكرون
بعد الاغلاقات الاخيره والتشديد اللي
شفناه تجديد الاجراءات على كرونا اللي
شفنا من الصين مشاهدين انا اعود معكم في
نبدا السوق للمزيد دعونا ننتقل مجددا الى
استديوهاتنا في الرياض مع الزميل احمد
شكرا شكرا
البرازيل بعد اقتحامات شهدتها المقرات
الحكوميه الرئيسيه ما دفع برئيس البرازيلي
الى اعلان تدخل الامريكي في العاصمه
البرازيليه حتى نهايه الشهر الحالي رئيس
البرازيلي اشار الى ان عده خطابات الرئيس
السابق شجاعه انصاره على الاقتحامات مشيرا
الى ان برازيليه شهدت قصورا امنيا ووصف دا
سيلفا في خطاب مثيره للشغب بانه مخربون
ومتعصبون مضيفا انهم سيعاقبون بقوه
القانون الكامله هم هم
المحكمه العليا البرازيليه حاكم
البرازيليه بارتكاب اخطاء سهله اقتحام
المقار الحكوميه وقررت ايضا تجميده مهام
الحاكم لثلاثه اشهر
سبايدر مان
والاعتقالات في حاله التلبس مستمره لانه
عمليا يحدث التلبس اثناء ارتكاب جريمه او
بعد ذلك بوقت قصير
[موسيقى]
انتقل رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكيه
الجمهوريه كيف المكار في زياره الرئيس
جاوبيدي للحدود الجنوبيه والتي تعاني من
مشكله تدفق المهاجرين والمخدرات وقام في
تغريده الله قام باول زياره حدوديه من اجل
التقاط الصوره بينما كان اضغطوا من اجل
العفو عن ملايين المهاجرين الذين عبروا
الحدوده الى الولايات المتحده بشكل غير
قانوني وتوعد مكان فيه بتحرك الجمهوريين
نحو محاسبه بعضهم وزير الداخليه في مجلس
النواب بسبب خلق اخطر ازمه الحدوديه في
التاريخ الامريكي
قبل ذلك مشاهدينا الزهر رئيس الحدود
الامريكيه المكسيكيه في اول زياره رسميه
له الى هذا البلد بعد اكثر من عامين على
توله منصبه ومن المنتظر ان يعقد بعض في
العاصمه مكسيكو اليوم اجتماعات ثنائيه مع
نظيره المكسيكي قبل قمه الازعماء امريكا
الشماليه غدا الثلاثاء مع رئيس الوزراء
الكندي جاستن تورادو وكان بيض اهلا خميس
خطه ادارته لمنع المهاجرين من كوبا
والحدود وتوسيع قوائم من يمكن طردهم الى
المكسيك السياسيه الاخرى
ادام مكتب الرئاسه في تايوان التدريبات
العسكريه الاخيره التي اجرتها الصيني
القرب من الجزيره قائلا الى السلام
والاستخاره في منطقه تايوان والمنطقه
مسؤوليه مشتركه لكل من طيبه وبكين وزاره
الدفاع التايواليه افاد برصد 57 طائره
صينيه خلال تدريبات بكين العسكريه قرب
الجزيره كما اوضح بيان مكتب الرئاسي ان
موقف تايوان واضح للغايه من حيث انها لن
تصاعد الصراعات او تثير الخلافات لكنها
ستودعها عن سيادتها وامها
تحاولوا ربات البيوت في مصر التعاطي مع
غلاء الاسعار بموجه بل بمجموعه من الحيل
منها ما يطلعنا عليه من خلال الانترنت او
الوصفات المنزليه المتورثه بعضهن لجاء
لتقليل الكمياتي والكف عن طلب الوجبات
الجاهزه والبعض الاخر بدا يتجه الاستبداد
الاصناف التي تباع في الافران على سبيل
المثال بخبزها في المنازل تابعه
لمواجهه مواجهه الغلاء المتلاحقه بدات ام
سحر في الاعتماد على نفسها في عمل
المخبوزات عوضا عن شرائها وبدات تبيع
الجيرانها واهل المنطقه
قبليها باعمل الحاجه دي اوزعها واطلع
الشغل الدنيا غاليه
بعد ما كان همم 13 وصل ل 20 وفي ناس
بتبيعه ب22 فعلا هم الاول كنت باجيب بال
50 كيلو فمع غلو الحياه بقيت اجيب 25 بس
لما الغلاء كده في بيتنا احسن منه حاجه
نظيفه ومن حاجه بناكلها برده
بدلا من شراء الاطعمه الجاهزه على سبيل
المثال
من النت برده بشوف الحاجات الحديثه بقى
اللي بتتعمل وباحاول اجربها بحاول اجرب
البيتزا المخبوزات يعني حاجات المخبوزات
اللي في الافران بحاول اعملها انا ببقى
اقل الامكانيات تقام الان معارض دول للسلع
الغذائيه في جميع المحافظات المصريه لبيع
السلعه بالتنسيق مع الشركات والغرف
التجاريه باقل من اثمانها في الاسواق او
في الوقت نفسه كثفت اجهزه الدوله من
الرقابه على الاسواق وطرحت كميات من السلع
التي تباعه على بطاقات التموين باسعار
ثابته منذ فتره طويله وهو ما يرحب به
التجار لان انت دلوقت لما يكون عندك السكر
بعث 10 جنيه ونصف وساب السعر وبيكافر 65
مليون مواطن
فالسعر الحر همم لو عمل شويه ما بقاش في
تكالب عليه يعني فالتوازن ده اهم حاجه
للحكومه عاملات التوازن واهم حاجه السرعه
موجوده
بينزل من الشركه الشركات على نفسها علشان
همم ضبط اي همم مخالفات او تجاولات بتحصل
في موضوع السفر ارتفاع الاسعار يؤثر على
جميع الفئات بشكل او باخر وبينما ياخذ
الامر شكلا ساخرا على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي تزداد مشاهدات الفيديوهات
الخاصه باعداد الاكلات بطريقه اقتصاديه
بينما تدعو ام سحر الا يتجه جميع زبائنها
للخبز في المنازل حتى تجد من تبيع له هذا
الخبز الشهي تامر نصره العربيه القاهره
بعد ايام من طرح مذكرات الامير هادي للبيع
والتي تضمنت مزاعم جديده على خلاف
والشقاقي داخل العائله المالك البريطانيه
يستعد هاري لوابل مقابلات المثيره للجدل
في كل مره حاولت فيها القيام بذلك بخصوصيه
كانت هناك ايحاطات وتسريبات وخلق قصص ضد
زوجتي دراما ملكيه بامتياز بدات قبل سنوات
بطلها الامير البريطاني هاري وزوجته
الامريكيه مجانا هرب من قفص الملكيه بحثا
عن حريه يدعيان انهما سلبياتها ورغبه
منهما بالابتعاد عن الاضواء
الا ان ظهور الثنائي ميغان وهاري بات اكثر
مما كان عليه عندما كان تحتسق في قصر
باكينغهام احدها كان مع برنامج
كانت تدور معظمها حول كواليس حياتهما
السابقه
بتصريحات الناريه عزازه الفجوه بينهما
وبين العائله الملكيه البريطانيه التي
يزعم هاري بانهم استخدموا وسائل الاعلام
ضدهما
المثير للسخريه هنا هو طرح مذكرات الامير
هاري للبيع قبل الموعد الرسمي لنشرها
مذكرات تضمنت مزاعم جديده عن الخلاف
والشقاق داخل العائله الملكه البريطانيه
واتهامات وجهها الامير هاري لشقيقه ولي
العهد البريطاني واليمن بالتعدي الجسدي
عليه حسب ما نقلته صحيفه عن تسريبات
الكتاب التي تقول ان الامير واليمن امير
ويلز وريث العرش وشقيقه هاري الاكبر اوقع
اخاه ارضا في شجار
كما ان هاري زعم ايضا ان شقيقه وليم تطاول
لفظيا على ميجا واصفا اياها بالصعبه
والوقحاء والمزيفه
الشهره التي اكتسبها هاري وميغن منذ ان
تخليا عن واجباتهما الملكيه في عام 2020
بدات ترتد عليهما بالعكس حسب استطلاعات
للراي فالكثير من البريطانيين ذاقوا ذرعا
بملو دراما العائله المالكيه برمتها وان
الكشف عن مزيد من المفاجات لن يغير ارائهم
سواء متعاطفه مع هاري وزوجته ميجان ماركل
او تلك المنتقدتها لهما
روان حمزه العربيه
الجديده
امام سجن كرج
الدفاع البريطانيه تقول ان روسيا استخدمت
مقاتله من الجيل الخامس في اوكرانيا
على وقع القلق الامريكي من توجهات حكومه
نتنياهو بلنكني يزور اسرائيل نهايه الشهر
الجاري
ونجاح عمليه تعويم السفينه جلوري وعوده
حركه الملاحه لطبيعتها
نهايه هذه الساعه الاخباريه مشاهدينا شكرا
لحسن المتابعه ويمكنكم المتابعه ايضا في
العربيه دوت نت في امان الله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]